proof positive of modern thinking every
problem that you have can be cured with
a pill actually that would be really
badass limitless limitless is a story of
Bradley Cooper who's a struggling writer
has not written one page of his new book
he lives like a slob respect to that and
so this one guy offers him the solution
to his problems it's a pill that unlocks
the rest of his brain yeah we all use
like 10% this unlocks the other 90s
pretty much like viagra for your brain
that is what you call a mind [ __ ] and so
Bradley Cooper takes it and then life is
good now this movie is relatable to
everybody because no matter what your
dream is being astronaut a cop a writer
a director a garbage man I'm sure some
people dream of making the world a
cleaner place whatever your dream is it
can be boiled down to you want to be a
better version of yourself and that's
exactly what Bradley Cooper gets to be
in this movie so we all relate to it and
we like seeing it problem is with every
pill there are side effects and
consequences and people who want to kill
you for it now in the trailer to this
movie it made it look like Robert De
Niro's like the main bad guy but he's
really not it's this Russian dude in
fact Robert De Niro is ultimately an
extended cameo and the Russian bad guy
ultimately feels like a small part in
the movie the main point in the movie is
Bradley Cooper unlocking his brain with
this pill the bad guy is ultimately the
pill itself but it doesn't matter
because it's still interesting because
we all want to see what would happen if
a person could just see math become a
millionaire in like a week unlock his
brain I'm not gonna lie if that pill
existed I would take it like now the
movie feels kind of disjointed in parts
but there's a part of me that thinks
yeah that's kind of the point it does do
this weird camera thing like it zooms
through the city but it's like zooming
into photo after photo after photo after
photos ultimately what it feels like it
made me feel like I had the bed spins
watching that while I'm hammered forget
about it however you should watch it
while you're hammered let me know what
you think and Bradley Cooper was really
good in the movie he shows that he can
play in movies like The Hangover but he
can also play the serious roles dudes
here to stay because every chick wants
to bang Bradley Cooper and every dude
ultimately wants to be Bradley Cooper
whose face man
[ __ ] and some dudes do want to bang him
so limitless was exciting intriguing had
a really cool premise was actually kind
of liberating to watch I like seeing
people who become super geniuses like
phenomenon - the brain cancer in the
superpowers which really makes me think
if he unlocked 100 percent of his brain
wouldn't he be able to have telepathy
he's throwing that out there
but hey playing the stock market
becoming a millionaire nothing wrong
with that that's a superpower on its own
so again I would say I would
I limitless even on blu-ray even though
it was kind of disjointed in parson it
felt like the movie just ended like it's
going and then up over and subbu to the
end the movie still cool I mean if I had
a pill that made me super smart I would
exact revenge on everyone who pisses me
off I mean yeah stock markets great too
but come on so if you had a pill but
made you super smart four-digit IT you
smarter than Q from Star Trek what would
you do comment below let me know but if
you like what you seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more